en tout cas on peut parler d'une année
particulièrement difficile pour les
agriculteurs devant les membres de l'ue
pea aujourd'hui réunis en congrès à
québec
le président marcel groleau a proposé à
la ministre fédérale de l'agriculture
marie claude bibeau nouveau plan de
gestion de risques proposition 15 % des
pertes à la charge des producteurs 15%
assumée par ottawa et à québec et au
delà de 30 % de perte totale les
perturbations mais entièrement par
ottawa
marcel groleau et à québec bon soir
monsieur gros lot oui bonsoir on peut
dire que l'année 2019 est une année très
difficile pour les agriculteurs comment
est le moral des troupes
en fait c'est une année où on a connu
des hauts et des bas on vit toujours
d'espoir lorsqu'il s'agit de conditions
météorologiques donc un printemps tardif
on avait espoir que l'été nous permettre
de rattraper un peu la situation
un auto natif de nay de la neige aussi
tôt en saison puis la grève du cn et la
pénurie de propane alors tout ce combiné
josiel que moi les bons ceux qui ont
terminé leurs récoltes de maïs le sont
contents mais c'est ce que les pertes
vont être importantes puis on estime le
cpt
on n'a pas le bilan car ça va prendre
encore quelques semaines avant de voir
d'avoir le bilan complet mais les pertes
cette année seront importantes pour les
comptes twitter de céréales puis ils
l'ont été pour les producteurs de porcs
aussi qui eux estimaient escomptaient
une très bonne année due au conflit
entre la chine et les états unis mais
finalement le canada a été happé dans ce
conflit là et finalement ils vont avoir
une année très heureux très long très
très ordinaire parlons justement des
deux paliers de gouvernements
gouvernement du québec d'abord françois
legault a dit que la crise du propane
qui est un problème aussi pour les
producteurs de grains devait nous amener
à une transition vers l'électricité
quelles leçons vous tirer de cette crise
du programme d'abord que non on n'a pas
de stock on est un just in time
excusez l'expression mais moi je crois
qu'il faudra voir d'abord est-ce qu'on
peut stocker davantage pour parer à une
éventuelle
un conflit oui ça peut arriver à nouveau
mais si un bris sur les voies ferrées
s'il ya des contraintes l
approvisionnement avoir un peu plus de
stock devant nous là où c'est possible
on va suggérer d'amener le gaz naturel
on a certaines régions où le gaz naturel
est déjà fermée est pas distribuée
partout donc peut-être là où c'est
possible de distribuer à des coûts
raisonnables propos prioriser cette voie
là la troisième voie c'est par
l'électricité mais on a besoin d'eux du
réseau triphasé ça aussi c'est une
option encore plus écologique au québec
alors est ce que cette option là et
rentable ça coûte ça coûte très cher le
déployer le tri phasé pl actuellement
c'est à la charge des utilisateurs
lorsqu'on doit amener le tri phasé
jusqu'à la ferme à la cd option qui
existent mais faudra voir lesquels sont
les plus les plus rentables à développer
qu'elle était quelle a été la réception
de madame bebo à vos propositions
aujourd'hui d'un plan de gestion de
crise y ait eu bien sûr les problèmes
avec les américains toute la gestion de
l'offre les problèmes avec les chinois
le port le canola également dans
l'ensemble du canada
votre proposition est elle bien
accueilli oui alors ne nous raconte pas
privés après on à échanger davantage et
5 secondes
selon nous la proposition qu'on fait est
un meilleur partage des risques
un regard des responsabilités que
devrait assumer chacun des paliers de
gouvernement et ses comparables
également à ce qui se fait dans les
autres états comme les états unis n'ont
entre autres
donc on demande au fédéral d'assumer une
partie plus importante des risques
lorsque le niveau de perte dépasse 30%
et de partager un 15 % de perte dans un
programme fédéral provincial et là les
pourcentages pour assumer que devra
assumer les provinces où le fédéral
peuvent à être négocié discuté mais sont
revenus
on s'est mis d'accord avec ça ben non
pas d'accord le poids de i will a
d'emblée l'audi par contre qu'elle
allait vraiment prendre le temps
d'évaluer cette proposition là parce
qu'elle l'a déclaré dans son message
devant les congressistes que c'était
dans son mandat d'améliorer les
programmes de gestion des risques en
agriculture en tant que ministre de
l'agriculture
alors un seul mandat qu'elle a reçu du
22 sont au gouvernement donc nous on a
de l'espoir que cette proposition ne
puisse faire son chemin
juste une proposition qui recueille raid
à notre avis l'unanimité des provinces
également oui ça coûtera un peu plus
cher aux provinces cette proposition là
mais ça limite les risques des provinces
plus qu'à partir d'un certain niveau
c'est le fédéral qui prendrait la relève
alors pour nous c'est une proposition
qui est balancé en regard des
responsabilités de chacun des paliers de
gouvernement je vous entendre sur les
pesticides de monsieur grelots parce
qu'aujourd'hui on vous a écouté au
congrès qui vous avait parlé
d'acharnement médiatique sur le reste
c'est d'aujourd'hui vous voulez dire
quoi en fait j'ai exprimé ce que les
producteurs ont ressenti cette année
parce que les producteurs ont vraiment
l'impression d'avoir fait des pas
importants dans la gestion des
pesticides dans la protection de
l'environnement protection de l'eau on
sait qu'ils encore des pas à faire on
doit continuer de s'améliorer
on a une réglementation déjà très
exigeant j'ai parlé aussi pendant le
congrès de réduire la le poids des
programmes où l'administration des
programmes et de nos relations avec
l'état qui est déjà un fardeau pour les
conducteurs alors la couverture cet été
était importante
puis elle n'était pas elle met en
évidence la en jeu mais ne mettait pas
en évidence les travaux que les
producteurs ont fait pour s'améliorer au
fil des ans mais elle ne met pas en
évidence un enjeu qui était pas
suffisamment traité c'est à dire qu'on a
assez loin sur ces questions là et qui
avait une information qui n'était pas
diffusée ben je on pourra voir nos
points de vue là-dessus mais moi je veux
pas parler uniquement de la couverture
qui a été fait par radio canada
on a eu d'autres
ouverture où on voulait vraiment prendre
en défaut les producteurs dans dés
étaient c'était vraiment pour alimenter
le débat plutôt que pour informer sur la
situation que vivent les producteurs et
les la façon dont les producteurs
tentent de minimiser l'impact de
l'utilisation de ces produits
alors je pense qu'il y aurait pu y avoir
un équilibre un peu plus un peu plus
dans ce dossier là sur le traitement de
l'information
parce que je j'ai donné par exemple
comme pour le démontrer lorsque le
résultat sur la présence de pesticides
sur les fruits a été rendu public
c'était des bons résultats 95 % et + des
fruits a inspecté répondaient aux normes
de santé canada c'est donc dire que les
producteurs utilisent rigoureusement les
pesticides qu'ils mettent sur leurs
champs pour traiter donc moi je sais
c'était enfin une bonne nouvelle puisque
les produits importés étaient moins par
le pré présentée plus d'un pesticide
coup de résidus de pesticides que ceux
du québec
alors il y aurait pu avoir une bonne
nouvelle mais finalement ça peut te
présenter comme ça voilà parfait on va
s'arrêter ici le congrès se poursuit
cette semaine
merci monsieur gros lot ça me plaisait
au revoir